All right. Hey, what's going on everybody?
It's bill bar and it's time for the
Thursday afternoon, just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast ad.
I'm just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on your
week here and usually, you know,
what do I usually do? I usually sit here
and my fucking pajamas like fucking,
you know, give you a little half hour
fucking bullshit to try. But it's payday,
right?
You don't need a full show.
You have probably half in the bag and
a fucking El Torito at this point.
If you listen to it,
you shouldn't be driving.
But every once in awhile I do have
a guest. I do have a guest in today.
We have the great Joe Rogan.
Hey fucking uh,
grand national champion at Tae Kwan
Doe sitcoms star fucking reality show a
commentator right across the board.
Al Conner.
Wild boar hunter.
I don't know what a fucking conspiracy
theory. Fucking whatever you want.
This guy is his own fucking entity.
Andy, as a brand new killer,
special on Netflix entitled triggered,
please welcome Joe Rogan.
Thanks Bill Burns going on. Long time
coming, dude. I know. Long time coming.
I love your show. I have on mine a bunch
of times, so I know to be on yours,
but you're a big like interview guy on,
I'm like a fucking lunatic who just sits
in the corner of his house and every
once in awhile my wife walks by and I
love the style that you do cause it's very
unique.
You know,
I've done a couple like that where
answer questions and stuff like that,
but it's a very unique style of,
you know,
I think it lends itself really well to
stand up and to developing bits too.
I just didn't want to deal
with having to like book.
Like you'll find you're simply okay,
come down to my studio. Perfect.
You know what I mean?
But like I just didn't want it.
I saw what other people were going
through. Like, oh, I got an audition,
can we make it four o'clock?
And I was just like,
I don't want to fucking deal
with that stuff. But, um,
um, but when I, if you know,
if everyone can be a guest like yourself,
can I start with the elk thing? Yeah.
Because I am fascinated with hunting.
I think it's bad ass.
I think everybody should know how to
do it. And in, I'm not one of the,
I am an animal lover,
but I'm not going to be that hypocritical
one that fucking eat chickens that had
their fucking beaks clipped off
and they got the roided out.
Mark McGuire breastplate that
tipping over in the coops,
all that shit that you see. And
then I'm going to be like, oh,
could you shoot a fucking pheasant or
whatever the hell you're shooting out
there. But um, I retweeted a
picture of you got this. What is it?
You said it was a 12 point
or why do you say six?
[inaudible] six by six they
call it a straight six L
it's a six by six or seven meets big
elk. That was the, I've shot three hours.
That's the biggest one by far. Then one
was monsters was huge. So what is the, uh,
this is the thing that always
fascinates me about hunting shows is the
nervousness and the whispering before you
take the shot though, it's like, okay,
there it is. Yeah, just relax. Can
exhale and just like if you miss,
I mean it's the fucking thing going to
come running at, you know, it seems like,
cause it does. I am not to Spook
it because you have to have it
close enough for you to shoot it.
Depending upon how you're shooting it.
If you shouldn't be with a bow and Arrow,
you've got to be real close.
You've got to be inside of 60 yards.
Most times bad ass.
I shot one with the bow and arrow.
That one out there,
the big one I shot with a rifle dude,
a bow and arrow. That's, that's to me,
that's the Shit I saw Ted Nugent.
He shot a fucking bear, you know,
which I could never do.
I fucking love bears this certain animals.
But you know what I mean? Bears
are interesting. I've, I've,
I've shot bears you showed up there,
so I'll get you some bare sausage.
I can't even bear, I've shot three bears
with, I can't eat it back. They're good.
And I knew about shares.
I bet you like delicious.
You're like a fucking sirloin.
Well, we, uh, a filet Mignon,
you got like no women met
on tender and juicy. Um,
I've always felt that about you,
Joe. Thank you. We think of bears,
I think very incorrectly because with the,
you know what the word
a anthropomorphization
means when you put human
characteristics and animals like
Yogi bear and shit like that.
And we make them ride a
bicycle at the circus.
We have this idea that
bears are these cute things.
But where my friend lives
in Alberta where I hunt,
they literally have to shoot them
because they don't have any predators.
So if bears don't have any predators and
they just breed and they keep reading
and then they decimate the Moose
population, the elk population,
and they cannibalize each other.
That's the thing that most people,
they kind of handle it in house sort of,
but they eat babies.
That's what they do most of the time.
He babies,
they eat their own babies at sliders,
black bear sliders. Well, why wouldn't
you? Well, it's, it's brutal to see,
you know,
we've,
we've stumbled across pause and stuff
from a cubs with a male bores them.
That's what the ones that you should go
out when you just find a baby bear paw
in the woods. I mean a party,
his soul has to just fucking,
it's got to die or cry out. Like I,
that's something I never want to see.
It's very strange. I guess I do have to
admit though that uh, bear hunting's not,
I don't like it as much
as hunting other animals.
If I had to choose like what animal's
tongue, you can eat bear by the way.
And that's the only things that I
hunt is what I eat. Black bear. Uh,
you can eat grizzly bear
but they don't taste good.
Most of the reason for that because
grizzly bears mostly eaten meat.
They eat a few berries.
If you can find a grizzly bear
that was just eating berries,
it would probably taste delicious.
They literally taste like what they eat.
Like hunters try to go after bears,
eat berries,
like black bears in particular in
the fall they'll eat blueberries.
They called him blueberry bears.
Cause like as you're opening them up,
their fat is like a purple color
and it tastes like blueberries.
And apparently it's the most
delicious meat in the world.
So without them realizing that they're
already marinating themselves. Exactly.
You guys leave show cells
seasoning themselves.
But my all time favorite animals are elk.
That's the best. They taste the best.
The best for you. And gave
me that, that elk meat, uh,
whatever. The last time I was on here and
I made a chili out of it and then the,
if the fucking elk burgers,
it's a little dry.
Somebody gave me a hint to put a
little bit of butter in there to Kinda,
you know.
Yes.
You needed something like an egg or sell
to make it stick together a little bit.
You don't want it to cook it too much
cause it's super lean. There's no fan. No.
I put a piece of Swiss cheese and
some pursuit on top of fucking insane.
Feel good when you eat it too.
It's a powerful food.
There's a lot of energy in those. There's
like, there's so much nutrients in elk.
It's like way more protein dense,
way more nutrient dense,
but anything kind of like the
creek because they're wild.
I know like the human like
footprint as they said, you know,
acid rain and all the fucking horseshit
and we do, but at least it's, it's,
I would like to think it's kind of
away from the Gmos and all that.
It's a type of stuff can get.
So it's who knows what Gmos do to you,
but like the fresh shit
tastes better though. It does
taste. Does it taste better?
I mean Gmos, everything's,
gee, that's a weird word.
Like if you talk to real
scientists about Gmos,
most of the time when you talk about Gmos,
we're talking to hippies and like yo man,
you gotta to stay away from Gmos.
You mentioned ethically modified.
It's giving us cancer.
It's terrible for the water.
But real GMOs is almost everything we eat.
Every tomato you eat is
genetically modified.
They've all been all alternate Koran.
We kind of were kind of like
Guinea pigs to see like what,
what's going to happen sort of.
But most of it is just splicing.
Like I just found this out recently,
you know when you buy pistachios,
there's a place up in northern California
with CIOs a stash. It goes either way.
She's not shoes. Tony, who you talking
to? [inaudible] did that. Thank you. Stop.
She has talent shows since
you need some pistachio.
I like it with the tea shelled. Of
course. I don't Sheldon. I so I,
I buy shelled pistachios and I feel like
I'm cheating because I just take big
handfuls of them and shoving my
fat face. You can't do that. Yeah.
There's a reason why there's a
shell on it because if you don't,
you're gonna need a thousand of
them. I buy them in these big, uh,
like a two pound boxes and I just pour
my hands on. I eat them. The good,
good for you too. It's kind of guilt
free, but you feel like you're cheating.
Like you don't have to crack them.
I know I stared you off course.
So you were still talking to the native
when they grow these pistachios is
pistachio trees. The pistachio
bushes are not a big strong tree.
So they graft the limbs of the pistachio
tree onto like an avocado tree,
a thicker, stronger tree and they'd
grow pistachios on and avocado free.
Like what the fuck? But Yo, how
are we playing God that, oh,
we're playing God by driving cars too,
but playing God by flying planes.
That shit is like, first of all, I
thought pistachios came from the ground.
I thought penis were in the ground.
Peanuts,
I think peanuts are in the ground is
a pistachio. Know George W was the,
Jimmy Carter was a peanut farmer.
How did he do it? She didn't ask him.
I think it was in the ground.
I don't know. Fucking upset.
That's why I want a hunt.
Carrots are in the ground and OCR worms,
they're in the ground. Do you grow? And
he says, I was trying to recover it.
That we don't notice it in the ground.
Birds are in this guy dirt.
Um, do I know? I mean my, my, my,
the guy who cuts the grass fucking
put him on. So I got tomatoes,
I got lemons and limes. But all that
did was just make me fucking booze more.
Cause I'm just,
I get totally
got into Kipp Tequila.
It's like there's only so much
guacamole you can eat and you just like,
what the fuck else can I do with this
shit? Um, so I kinda got into Tequila.
It's less of a hangover and do,
and I'm telling you get one of those
big square ice cubes are really nice to
keep just like a patrol in silver.
He put that in there and then you go
pick a fucking lime off. I'm telling you,
it's why it's why I live out here.
It's not the show Biz. It's the booze.
Well, you don't really have to
live out here anymore. Right.
And especially like your podcast, the
way you do your podcast, you just rant.
Like you could do that fucking thing
and you do do it anyway. But I also, uh,
you know, my wife's in the business
too, so she does acting. She just,
she's doing a voiceover today and uh,
so she doesn't have that luxury.
And then also, you know, um, she would go,
she would go crazy if,
if I, if I, you know,
if I just moved to like the middle of
fucking now my saying and lived in the
middle of fucking nowhere, but
I do, when I go on the road,
I always have that urge.
Like when I go to a place and I just
started thinking about, hey man,
these guys riding around motorcycles,
no helmets on, and it's just like this,
that at lake water here they
got, they got, they got that.
It's very lush land. Like living
out here is, is a, it's terrifying.
It's terrifying. Like what, what
happened to the water in silver link?
Where did they take that? They closed
several Lincoln actual lake at one point.
Yeah, it was manmade, but the water's all
gone now. They're going to develop it in,
yeah. They said they put it under ground.
They didn't really say where. It's just,
it's just gone. Yeah. To when I fly,
let's say it's one of the things I fucker
would look down and you go with dodger
stadium and then you start coming.
Then you see silver lake and I'm looking
down like where'd that parking lot with
the big top come from? And the guy
was like, oh, that was silver guy.
They drained the water. I don't know,
they said they put it under ground.
It's all like vague through,
do you know when I was in,
I was in Nashville this past weekend and
I was sitting there watching the news
during the day and they
just go like, Oh, and folks,
if you're in the downtown area and you
see the police doing something that seems
a little disturbing. Ah, tell
worry. It's just an exercise.
And then they continued on and it was
just like, you didn't do any followup.
Like there's no more information with an
exercise. What are they practicing for?
That whatever they're doing is,
is like scary.
Now I'm not saying they're
going to come at us.
Is it some sort of anti terrorism thing?
I have no fucking idea what it was.
But like just the,
the kind of vagueness that two days
right before the Dodgers scored the other
day, uh, NPR, my wife listens
to that shit and I, you know,
[inaudible] morning becomes
eclectic if you enjoy this show.
Fresh air with Terry Gross.
Yeah.
There's always those pauses and a chill
when you first started doing standard,
you know what I think of, of discusses
before, but it's kind of important,
you know what to think of
when I think of those people.
Do you know who that Guy John Ghomeshi is?
I like NPR,
but it's so easily to be made fun of.
It's easy to drive off the road into a
fucking tree when you're listening to it,
to you. Oh yeah, no,
there's a lot of droning on.
But [inaudible] talk,
which nobody does that super sensitive
leftwing style of talk. The guy that
was, uh, he'd do that really well.
The main guy that did that. It
was this guy, John Ghomeshi,
who was on the CBC in Canada and it turned
out he liked to beat the fuck out of
girls when he was having sex with them.
He would punch him in the face and club.
I'm in the head and it was crazy shit.
And one girl I aim at. Yeah, yeah. Want.
And he would do it without asking them.
It was like, you know, like the, you know,
that's a strong move. It's crazy
strong move in the rack. Well,
I mean who knows who's telling the truth.
Cause he was kind of acquitted of a lot
of it. It was, it's, it's, cause it was,
it was very difficult to find evidence
on money to get acquitted, you know.
Well that's true.
That's a good point.
But he was fired and there was a gang of
girls that came out and said he used to
pick them up. Oh wait,
wait, wait. What did that,
the Gao does the interviews
like this bill burrs.
So tell me one time when
I'm not saying all those,
I don't know what the fuck
he does in his personal life,
but Russell Peters was on there and he
just goes like, and he's like, Russell,
you have nine cars. And Russell's
like, yeah. And he goes, why?
And it just fucking like making him
feel bad cause he's doing well, he's,
you know,
and then Russell had the fucking basically
justified and come up with money and
now I can have it and I'm sorry I
fucking made it. Wow. And I like cars.
Wow. Yes. So No,
I'm not saying he's a Twat that's
just saying this right there. Well,
even if they're that bug me,
I hate when people fucking do
stuff like that to hit somebody.
If you get like eight or nine chicks,
they're saying you beat the fuck
out of him while you're having sex.
Even if you get what somebody got cracked,
what is your number that innocent
until guilty or how many accusations?
Bill Cosby I gave in around 30 30
I heard the first,
we had heard that right around seven.
No, I, there was rumors of his infidelity,
but I never heard of drugging.
You never heard that? No, I did.
I heard that.
I had heard that it was like a rumor.
It was a rumor that he had drug women.
It was a rumor a long time ago. He was a,
there was a court case that
is part of this case from,
I believe it was like 2005 and that
was one of the reasons why they weren't
allowed to admit that evidence because
the judge had made a decision that if he
paid this woman off, then it couldn't
be admissible in a future trial.
But it was all verbal.
They didn't get anything on paper.
So once they found out that it didn't
get this on paper, they're like, well,
we're gonna admit this.
And then the woman came out and then he
sued the woman that he gave the money to
for drug inner. Oh, the whole thing is
very, very sorted. But with Bill Cosby,
I think it's up to like 50 or something
crazy. Yeah. So you got to wonder,
out of those 50 does probably like 12 that
are just crazy. Like he dragged me to,
you know,
it's about the fact,
but the fact that he'd still be
open 30 it's just nuts. I think,
you know what you know,
you know,
it was one when all that shit came
out about Trump, right? He did this,
he did that, blah, blah, blah. It was
all pretty pedestrian sort of like, oh,
he grabbed my boob and then took me
in the back. Just just really sort
of lights become sort of the cliched
story. And then this one woman,
so I'm sitting there going like,
guide, the Clintons are fucking filthy.
Who knows if they paid these people,
who knows what the fuck's going on?
It's right before the list of when
this is coming out. And so I was going,
all right, we'll see, we'll
see. And then this finally,
this woman came on and she goes,
uh,
so he made advancements at me and she
goes, I just pushed him away and said,
get real. Which is the perfect thing to
say, cause you're, you're in your 20s.
He's like, fucking 106 it's like, yeah,
you serious? She goes, I said, get real.
And then she said he trusted his genitals
towards me and these and said get re.
Yeah, she said that. And
the way she imitated them, I
was in the car with my wife.
I say he fucking did that dial and
there's no fucking way that it's just too
specific. Like I got the
creeps up like you hit real,
so wonder what the logistics are,
where the legality is rather of the,
the audio tape. Like if you
don't know you're being recorded,
like you know you're being recorded for
a show. You're wearing a microphone,
but you don't know you're being recorded
while you're on a bus and you're
talking about grabbing them
by the pussy and all that.
He was talking to me talking trash.
He's talking shit. Yeah, like it.
Joey Diaz would say something like that
and I'd be fucking crying, laughing,
and he would be egging it up.
He would ramp it up.
He would make it way exaggerated
because he knows it's funny.
He's gone for the land. If you're
sitting next to Trump and he's like,
I just grabbed by the pussy,
you'd be fucking crying laughing.
That's why it just ut Bush. I
defended him on my podcast. It's like,
I'm not saying that guy's a great guy,
but if fire a fucking guy because of
a fucking 22nd clip from 11 years ago,
what's he supposed to do?
He's interviewing the guy and what you
supposed to do was keep the interview I
happiness interviewee happy, so
he's at grand by the Po's. Hey,
grab 'em by the Pussy. Yeah. He
just didn't even say anything bad.
Billy Bush didn't say anything bad.
It just launch. This guy at work said,
well when he said to the woman,
go over and give him a hug,
he became part of the sexual
assault and I was just like,
what sector was no sexual assault?
What they was saying,
if he actually did it was the
whole thing was just like,
let's just,
you know,
I understand women get in flipping out
about it as far as obviously just the
whole,
it would be them,
but what they don't know is the way
guys taught when they're not there yet.
And I'm just gonna,
I'm going to sit to the fucking shit
that we've said and we say it for fun.
You don't say it because we really want
to go grab someone by the Pussy and pick
them up like a bowling ball and say
it because it's funny. It's funny.
And you just, you're talking completely
ridiculous and inappropriate. Yes. Yeah.
Like say example. I will say, if
you do have $1 billion, I, um,
what I'm learning through Cosby at all
these fucking guys is evidently you can
do that. And he did say that he's
going like, you get famous enough,
you can just want to come from grand
by the pussy. And I've just said,
that was just so absurd to me. I'm like,
you can do that. You can't do that.
But he's got so much money.
You've got to think when you get off
that that guy could get you six grand in
cash. If he gave me five
weeks, I just don't correct.
I think he's leveraged out tiny bit,
but I'm pretty sure he'd go
to the ATM and get six grand,
but I know you're exaggerating
to six grand's a funny number.
It's a funny number. It
is funny. I'm just saying,
right dude is like liquid rich and your
assets have paid off and then there's,
oh,
I got this,
I'm going to take a loan against this and
then I'm going to do that and get some
investors here and then I would stick
my fucking name on it to build my brand.
There's that way where you're sort
of like steroid and up your value,
but at the end of the day it's
like, all right, but what?
How much can you get me right fucking now?
Like I don't get that whole like, well,
all my shit's tied up and I got other
guys, you know I'm, I'm working with Lily.
See the Zeros. What's in your
bank account? Show me. Yes.
Phone. Yes. Sean helicopter.
That helicopter with your name on the
back. Is that paid off? Is that a sticker?
But he's got a sticker that they take
off and then they put fucking Mark Cuban
on the back. But if name woman showing
up at his house and you're having,
you're supposed to have a business lunch,
you don't know that you show up.
He's got this sprawling estate
that looks like a castle.
He's got these enormous grounds.
He's probably got 50 people working just
at his house. Cause my greeting you,
they're taking you into these rooms.
He comes out in a $10,000 suit,
he's got diamonds and Rolexes and
everything's beautiful. And you're like,
Holy Shit,
it's Donald Trump is too,
pays like 80 grand this fucking hair.
Why doesn't he go the way you and I did.
You and I recognize it was over because
I don't think it was acceptable back
then, but it's, except Jordan
had to make it acceptable.
Jordan made it except made
except for four black guys.
He transcends Willis curly
Neal of the globe trotters.
It's made it acceptable for black guys.
And then Jordan was just, you know,
everyone wanted to be like Mike.
And I remember when he was at the height,
there was black guys
young with the full head.
Their fucking hair would shave their head
just to look like those fucking insane.
They'll do that.
Well what about Yule Brenner?
Yule Brenner was the first white guy
to rocket and be a movie star. Oh yeah.
The king and I Westworld, the original
Westworld, not the HBO series. You know,
I tried to buy the rights to that like
fucking 10 years ago. You did? Yes. World.
Yeah. I don't know what I was
going to buy. I was just like,
this is a movie that someone's going to
want to read too because they redoing
all these movies from my
childhood and I was just like,
I fucking loved that movie.
And I thing really loans itself because
we're not at the point where you can do
any of this shit. So it's still in the
future. You could totally but that,
but they wanted like
a zillion dollars for,
I didn't really get with Michael
Crighton book and all that.
They wanted like millions and millions.
And I was just like, all right,
I don't know, I'll tell you, get it for
like fucking 30 grand, like a Prius. Um,
if you watch the show or this thing.
Then the second I sat down
and I watched the show,
I just watched the opening credits
and I was like, oh, thank God,
thank God I didn't have the rights to
that cause there's no fucking way I could
have pulled that off.
Like all the things like the horse
running in those tendons connecting. Um,
I've watched the first two episodes.
I'm totally in and uh,
I've already bugged my agent to
be like, dude, I will fucking,
the same way when I saw breaking bad,
I just like,
I watched the first two
episodes and I was like, dude,
I will carry a tray of meth in the
background, whatever you can plug into.
So I bugged him going like,
um,
I'm actually bullshit and
that's on my agenda today.
I'm going to want to get out of
this and I'm what we're done here.
And I'd walk home with my elk meat,
hopefully. Um, I've got pounds for it.
I'm going to, uh, I'm going to, uh,
I'm going to bug him about trying,
trying to get on that thing.
And, uh, there's actually,
there's a couple of actors in there
that I've worked with, um, that, uh,
I'm just like that they're
on, you know, you see,
you see friends of yours that are
actually in there and they're on something
that fucking cool. Tate, my friend Tate
was on last week's episode. Yes. World.
He's on everything though. Tate's
Tate's been in, I know a hundred movies,
probably easily a hundred movies. I've
always wondered if, you know, when you're,
you're doing something correct because
it's so hard when you're shooting it and
how they just,
all right now his point of view,
we'll do the master of backpack
back and do all that type of stuff.
You just find yourself walking
around. Was it good? Did it, you know,
cause the camera crew's not
saying anything. Everybody's
fucking quiet. And it's,
uh, it really comes down though to the
editors and the music and all that.
They can either take it to the
next level or they can read,
they can make something good look great
and they can take something great look
fucking horrific.
Well something start off great and then
they don't know how to end it and they
fuck it up.
But there's something weird about having
a friend in a movie where you're going,
this movie's Great. Oh there's tape. Like
it takes you out of it. It's like, oh,
that's my friend. Like this
movie's bullshit. Yeah.
People always say it doesn't,
it doesn't, it doesn't take me. Uh,
it doesn't take me out of it unless
I see them like watching themselves.
Like I can't believe I'm in this
scene with this guy that then,
then it like pulls me out. But like I,
I, I buy in when I'm one of those guys.
Like I don't like going to horror
movies. Like they freak me out. I buy in,
I don't give a fuck what the concept is.
Like that fucking thing where the lady
was like flipping the light switch off
and then turning it on and then
flipped it off and saw the thing again.
And then turn it on and then flipped off.
It was right there.
I was literally at home and
my stop fucking turn in the
movies that I dunno,
like the movie was coming out and it
was like the thing where she's like,
she's like, you know when you look into
a room and you shut the lights off,
shuts the lights off and all of a
sudden there's this fucking thing there.
Sort of a girl sort of fucking Beasley
and it's across the room so you can't
quite see it. So it's just like, what
the fuck is that? Turns the lights on,
it's gone. Shuts it off.
It's there again. Same spot.
Turns the lights back on.
It's not there.
Shuts it up the third time and it's
right in her fucking grill. Yeah.
Scared the fuck out of me.
Blair witch, Blair witch.
When they would go like to move, you
didn't skip me. Ralphie may go to,
they didn't fucking scare me.
You scare the shit out of me.
I saw that movie by myself.
I'd done a spot at the laugh factory and
went down to the Mann's Chinese theater
though.
The one that got Hollywood galaxy.
I don't know if that's still
there anymore. Right next door.
And I saw like the midnight showing
by myself. Dude freaked those out.
Yeah. But nobody I knew and it
was like really sort of like,
there wasn't a lot of people there.
And then that walked through the
parking garage. Oh Dude, I was fucking,
I was freaked out. I saw
that movie in Houston, Texas.
Chris Mcguire and I did a show.
We did a show at the old laugh stop.
You ever do the old laptop?
Uh, I do that one Drake
club, I think I just,
whatever the classic one was
that Hixon all those guys,
it had just moved to the new spot to
spot sucked. The new spa was not good,
but the old spot was amazing. And that's
where I did my first album. That was a,
I'm going to be dead
Sunday. I did in 1999. Uh,
we did a show and then McGuire and I
met these kids that worked across the
street at the movie theater
and they go, Hey, do you guys,
we have the keys to the movie theater?
Do you guys want to go watch
the Blair witch? Just us.
And we were like, Holy Shit,
let's do it. So we left. We had a
10 o'clock show. It's like midnight.
We'd go across the street,
they fucking cook up the popcorn.
The whole deal gave us
free Sosa locked the door.
You couldn't even do that today.
No, it was amazing. I mean,
today everything's digital, you
know, the kids spools up the fucking,
the real and everything like that.
And we sat down in the theater,
it was like three of them and two of us
and we watched a Blair witch and shit.
Our pants. It was, oh, awesome.
Oh my God, Josh screaming.
I still remember that when the kid
staring in the corner like Ooh, oh yeah.
When they just sorta
like went past it again.
All of that shit where rather than just
showing you saw in somebody's head off.
Just the idea.
Yeah.
When you think of like Tarantino talked
about that were in reservoir dogs.
He had one scene where they showed the
guy hacking the year off versus just
panning away and hearing the
guy screaming. It's just like,
it was way more fucking disturbing that
that ruined that song for me for a long
time. I always tell what song was
that Marvin Nash screaming. Um, uh,
now here Stephen writes voice, uh, Lynn,
I don't know if Phil and he said,
Oh yeah, that was,
that's something to stop.
Remember that when he fucking he through
adding a fun song to a horrific scene.
Oh, that was so the powerlessness
of just fucking like,
I can't, I can't, I can't deal with,
that's like Scarface member's car face.
When they cut the guy up with a chainsaw,
he's tied up in the, in the bathtub
and they forced Tony Montana to watch.
He's getting splattered with blood
as a hack his friend up. Yeah. No,
my mother
took us to see that.
She didn't know what it was.
Took all of us to see it and my
youngest brother was like nine.
I think if my mother said
after these changes I've seen,
we have to get out of here,
I would have been like, fine.
Cause I've been watching that
going, oh, like it was really,
I asked my mother years later,
she was just like, well yeah,
I thought at that point, yes, that
it might've been a little mature,
mature for your youngest brother. And,
but I was laughing. I was going, yeah,
but you always took us to cool movie.
She goes and she goes, yeah. She goes,
that was a good move.
She goes,
I'm gonna take care of those stupid things
like she was against like the whole,
uh,
she took us to full love of Benji and
Herbie goes to Monte Carlo and then they,
my parents were just like, we're not
fucking sitting through this shit.
We're going to go to a movie
that we're going to enjoy it too.
And then I went from that to like,
and like scarf the appearances in
fuck kid man. Just said, fuck it.
We're going to go, we're going to go
out. We're going to go there. Yeah,
we're going to see something too. But
let's look at me. I'm sweating like a pig.
Can you turn the AC on? Yeah.
Let's, uh, let's get to, um,
let's get to what I wanted to promote
here. Uh, you got your stand up,
special trigger coming out.
So first it's out. All right.
And when is it,
when is it airing?
I'm not what I'm saying and I'm
going to say where did you shoot it?
Shot on bad as an interviewer.
I'm Ben too. It's,
I'm trying to think of what I'm
supposed to ask you about San Francisco,
the Fillmore, how you want to
do it at a comedy club. And uh,
there was like a debate
between Netflix and me.
Netflix wanted to do it at a huge place.
I wanted to do it at a tiny place cause
I did my last one at the comedy works in
Denver, which is only like a couple
of hundred people. And I liked that.
I think there's something about when
you're sitting in the living room and
you're sitting on the couch
and watching a comedy special,
it lends itself better to be in, in a,
like a club. When you're filming it,
it feels more intimate, you know, see like
you're on top of the crowd. It's like,
it's more like what it would be like the
environment that it would be. So, uh,
we made a compromise.
We did the Fillmore theater,
which is a fucking really cool theater,
and it's only 450 seats.
So it's pretty small.
It's got a high ceiling and it's kind
of a big stage and everything like that.
But it's fairly small place,
but as cool.
But next one I'm going to do
in a small place, I think,
I think I might do with the store.
Now what's funny is when I went
to go do mine at the Tabernacle,
you had already been there and did one.
So I was like,
how am I gonna make this different?
And I did the Fillmore in
2009 to let it go. I did that.
Yeah. So I think we're, yeah,
we're going back and forth and doing your
new one. Yeah. Uh, I did it last Friday.
You did it? Yep. I did it at the Ryman in
Nashville. Dude, I just, I was just there.
I fucking loved that play place is crazy.
He used to do the Grand Ole Opry,
sa Cedric the entertainer,
just a did one there. So I uh,
watched like the opening to his
just to see, cause I was just like,
cause then you've got to kind of disguise
it so it doesn't look like, oh my God,
he's at the exact same fucking
place. You know, the guy's huge,
so I had to make sure I will. It's like
all right, well we gotta try to, you know,
he came in with like a whole
marching band and all of that,
which is the exact opposite to my
style. So it was like, okay cool.
Kat Williams brought a lion. He brought
a lie in that stage. That's awesome.
I love that guy. That guy is fucking
hilarious man. He's fucking hilarious.
Funniest guys alive and you know,
and just having the balls to go on
stage with a fucking line is hilarious.
How do you come? I want to, I wish
I was in that fucking pitch meeting.
Here's the deal. What's the concept?
I'm coming on stage with a lion.
A lion in a cage. Like a stuff.
We're now a real one. He's,
he got so sweaty during this special,
he had a stop and change clothes.
Is that right?
Yeah,
he literally stopped cause I'll
be right back and went backstage.
Changed his fucking clothes was drenched.
I mean just completely soaked
with sweat is if they put,
when they put that HD makeup on and then
there's all those lights on you. Yeah.
And then then you're going hard.
Yeah.
Cause it's just special and you really
want to make sure you're going to get a
good one. And then if the
fucking AC is a little messed up,
if the crowd's all fucking packed in,
in the wrong venue yet you can
get yourself into a situation.
I don't wear makeup on those things.
I wouldn't wear it for comedy
central and award for the UFC.
I don't want her for anything.
Just like, I don't know,
this is what it looked like.
You know? I think it's good.
It came first of all from fear factor, uh,
when I first started doing fear factor,
they wanted, they would put like a little
anti shine on me, a little of this,
a little that and after a while I'm like,
look,
these fucking people are covered in blood.
I mean,
they've got dirt all over their face
and I'm sitting there with makeup on,
you have to touch me up in between scenes.
You know, how ridiculous that is. Yes.
And then we would go from that to
the UFC where people would literally,
their faces are getting busted open
their get giant fucking, it's funny,
I never noticed like when I watched you
on the UFC, I never noticed like, oh wow.
Like he can, he went on a TV
without makeup. That's so brave.
That's such a courageous thing.
I you just, you look like you.
Well that's what I look like. You
know, I'm just like, I'm not, you know,
Mike Goldberg gets it. They spray
it on. They got fucking airbrush.
I'm not kidding. Never an
airbrush. They do it to everybody.
All the ring girls and everything.
The airbrush room.
That's what they didn't go that fight.
I got up to my giant forehead.
I gotta get some [inaudible] Dude, I
got you Pete. Dude. Oh Gee. You guys,
you're not in the same way. Classes were
going crazy on stage. I sweat like crazy.
I mean, my last special, I looked at it
when I was doing the editing. I'm like,
Jesus, I'm a sweaty fuck. Like, it just
looks ridiculous. It looks like I'm like,
I'm on drugs,
but you're up there working and you're
not like just standing there. So this one,
I didn't have any, uh, this last one.
I, I made sure the AC was cranked.
Like with each special I learned
something. Yeah. Uh, so I was like,
make sure the,
you know,
the AC cranked don't fucking
cake the makeup on or whatever,
just so it was just a little bit of that.
That's all those stupid
little fucking things.
You know, don't stick my parents in
the front row please. Just beyond,
beyond, beyond the Pale. Yeah. And
I don't show any audience anymore.
I decided no more audience. She never
did. Yeah. That's their way to go.
No audience shots and everything.
Kind of mostly from the waist up.
Unless you need to see my legs for like
a particular thing I'm doing. Yeah.
I want to give away all your secrets
because of, because now I feel like,
um, because there's so
many specials coming out,
so many fucking special's
coming out that uh, you know,
that then it becomes like you, you have
to have like whatever you'll look is,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
the thing about it is you
have such a great act that's
going to stand on anyways,
but if you can add like your own sort
of style, the way you shoot them,
that becomes part of your thing.
That's another way to try to get it up.
Cause you know, you get on Netflix with
the specialist dude, you just, yeah,
you're fucking scrolling, scrolling,
scrolling, scrolling. Um, I guess so.
I just wanted it to be like,
you're watching it like no cutaways.
I don't want to cut into the left,
cut into the rye cut
and for no reason. Like, like a,
there was a director that I worked
with once who was like, you know,
we have to cut to the audience. You know,
that's how we're going to do our edits.
I go, let's just try and do with no
edits. We can't. I go, of course we can.
If I do a good show, we could deal with
no edits. He was like, no, look, trust me,
we're going to do this. I'm like,
no, this is my fucking special.
Like I don't even know
you. Yeah. Like you're,
you're coming in here and you wanted
to do all this stupid shit and,
and film the crowd and you know the people
want to know the people are laughing.
I'm like, they're going to hear them
laughing. I can take it in my opinion.
It takes you out of it feel cause
or one cell phone. Yeah. Perfect.
He sits down for like an hour and
40 minutes killing. They never,
they never go to the crowd.
The background just slowly
changes different colors
and guy absolutely murdered
you and I were supposed to go see bill
Cosby and Vegas. We had made like a,
we were talking about doing it,
but we both flaked and we
never wound up doing it.
And that's one of my
main regrets to this day.
I would have liked to see him
for the stink hit him. I didn't,
I saw it right before I met him and
then three months later I saw him.
Do you remember when he was doing shows?
Still like all those women were coming
out and he was still doing shows,
like he was still doing shows. He was
like, fuck it, I'm still doing them.
And he went out and he still did
those shows for a little while.
I think he thought he was powerful
enough to just sort of ignore it.
And then it wasn't going to La. It
wasn't going to come around. But dude,
I gotta tell you, if you gave me
a thousand guests, not a thousand,
but if you gave me 200 guesses,
his name would not be on that out of
all the fuck of all the fucking people.
Like if you, if you said, okay, this,
there's a comic out there doing this shit.
Really? You got your top 20 where
you'd be like, Oh yeah. You know what?
I never heard the rumors. I did hear
the rumors and also there was a time,
I don't mind, not in
the clubhouse. How am,
how am I a comedian this long and
I'm not fucking here in the rumors.
I heard it from Hollywood people.
I didn't hear it from comics.
I heard it from people in the business.
I heard it from like actors and from
people that like work on TV shows, sets.
I heard it during the news radio days.
I had heard it.
He was doing it at the show.
He was doing it for people that were
on the ship to two people allegedly,
who the fuck knows, but there's
something. It was something unbelievable,
unbelievably creepy.
But after the accusations came out,
when he was still doing shows,
he would go on stage with one.
I look into the left one.
I look at street movie.
He developed a dead I somewhere
along the line. Right.
So He'd go on stage with that weird,
I got him some slack. He's like nine.
I know they have it for the grace of
God, but he's dying. Right? I mean,
that's my point. It's like things
are falling off the wheels, right.
The wheels are falling off the ride and
he's got the shirt on this sweater on
that says hello friend.
And he's,
he's on stage and he walks out there and
everybody's clapping and cheering and
some guys, yeah, no, you're
right. Best you are a rapist.
And then,
you know,
they grabbed the guy and shuffle
them out and then people going,
we love you bill. And he just doesn't
even acknowledge that. Just ignore them.
Just ignore them. Yeah. It was something
crazy about that. It was like the last,
the last sparks before they
threw the water on the fire.
It's like there's just a little hope,
like, okay, guess need some embers,
last spark before they to the gas
roommate. I mean, his career, his life,
they threw water on him. Like,
I mean he's just, it's over.
Like no one's going to go
see him live now. Right.
I mean it's kind of over a dozen
water put out the sparks. Yes.
That's what I mean.
Through the water on them.
They said they wouldn't
that mean that he had no,
I mean like you had a moment of like,
there was still some sparks
in its colonial. Okay.
I can't get the accusations came out,
but he was still doing these shows and
people still came out and they're like,
we love you bill. He's got these
shares. Sign analogies. To me, I'm not,
I'm not the brightest guy.
It wasn't a good analogy.
You're analogy is probably better.
You know, the, the blowing the,
the flames on the fire. It's like, we
almost had it out. Like it was almost,
you know, my last flight sort of caught
on fire. Why helicopter flight? No,
no, no. We're playing air jet. Yeah. Back
from my special Nashville to La
and we got up to cruising altitude.
It smelled like burnt popcorn. So I was
like, did the Stewart, he says like,
I'll fast forward through
this. Cause I told her, he
told them, I think I was like,
did they burn the fucking
meal or something? And
then it sort of went away.
Then it kind of came back and I felt
this with everybody had the shades pulled
down.
I felt like we were starting to descend
and then it felt really like they felt
like the wing shaken and shit
and I was like, oh wow man.
Like there must be some turbulence.
I thought he was just descending to go
underneath it and then go back up again.
You only need to get a little
bit of a smoother air here.
Sorry about the movie ride.
I thought was gonna be doing that
shit and never said a fucking word.
And then all of a sudden like my drink
that was in the little middle armrests
started sliding forward like it was going
to fall onto the floor and I'm like,
oh fuck. And then the stewardess
came up. She goes, yeah,
we're going to be landing here shortly,
so I have to take those drinks. Right.
And then the woman next to me
said landed premature. Oh yeah.
We only 50 minutes into the
flight from Nashville to La.
My favorite thing was the woman next to
me takes the headphones off. She's like,
are we here already that we just fucking,
that we were on the Concorde?
I was like, no, it was on fire. I
don't know. I don't know what it was.
I always thinking like, oh fuck, this is
going to be something in somebody's bag.
Like the luggage is shit or
some shit like that value jet.
Something caught on fire underneath
there and like my whole thing was when we
were going down,
I wasn't nervous because he had full
control of the plane maneuvering and all
that and I just knew like yeah you,
you smell smoke. That is a a, a,
the procedure is land immediately.
So that's what he's doing and we're 30,000
feet up so he's going to land quickly.
That's the shaking. That's fine.
I feel as making turns. And banks,
everything's working. But
my whole thing is, you know,
I don't know anything about planes,
but I'm just like,
if it burns through the wrong wire,
if the hydraulics,
like what the fuck's going
to happen? So, um, yeah.
And we came into a landing in little
rock and then we came in like over this
river and I couldn't see the runway.
Oh. Cause you can't see straight.
So I'm just looking at the sign.
I just see this fucking river
and free to be following it.
That's what I'm thinking.
Like is he going to sell you this thing
and fucking sentence under the water?
Jesus. Um, and I was already thinking
and you know what's gonna Happen?
The front part of the plane's going to
get fucked up so that door's not gonna
open somebody's fucking fight.
Pass these FirstClass people into coach.
You know what I mean? We're real people
work. So they're going to be, oh,
they're going to out muscle me as they
get through. I'm going to be fucked.
If we use the first class, do, I can
take out the check next to me. I'm fine.
People are going to be unconscious anyway,
just from the stress and the impact.
Do you know, was uh,
was hilarious, was the,
the woman across the alphabet was totally
freaking out because unfortunately her
dad I guess had died in a plane crash,
so she was totally like totally fucking
hyperventilating to the point it was
making me angry.
Like how fucking freaked out she was.
What kills me is she's tall.
She's totally freaking out about that,
but I swear to God, Dude, like 10
minutes earlier barefoot walked in,
use the bathroom and came back out.
Like that doesn't scare her.
That doesn't scare her, but a fucking
a couple of lights on in the cockpit,
you know, and the smell of burnt
popcorn. Now she's freaking out barefoot.
What the Fuck I put in the
bathroom is a new thing.
I've been flying for 20 years.
I've never seen it.
It started with socks and now it's fun
socks or even fucking worse. He was like,
you still are.
But whatever happened to women where
they decided to wear shoes that hurt like
they always have. But what the
fuck is that about? That as such,
because we chose the of the,
of their lack of power, uh,
they couldn't get a good job.
You know what I mean? Believe me,
if it was switched to the other way,
if you made a dollar less an hour, I,
you could imagine the shoes should
be wearing right now, Joe. US enough.
That's not true. Yeah. Do you know
that that whole thing about the, the,
the gender disparity, the wage gap is
not true. Do you know what the very,
that actually is? It's choices
in jobs. It's not job for job.
Like if you were an engineer and
you're working next to a woman,
she wouldn't be making 70 cents to
your dollar. It's bullshit. It's a lie.
And it's one of those propaganda
things that they like to tout out.
And you heard fucking Obama talk about
and Sarah Silverman talked about and when
she was trying to get Hillary
Clinton elected, it's a,
it's a weird thing that people keep.
I thought she was [inaudible] Sanders.
I thought Sarah Sylvan
was with Hillary Clinton.
I thought it was initially Bernie Sanders
and then maybe show us and everybody
jumped ship and went fucking Hillary,
including Bernie,
who then fucking endorsed Hillary.
And it's like, well, why would you do?
You're right. It might be
Bernie. She was endorsing,
but it's that thing that they say that's
just not true. What it is. It's two.
It's two factors. One,
there's a lot of this,
the less hours women
tend to work less hours.
They also tend to take risks
because they had less easy. Well,
it just kids and Charles Park
joking a maternity leave, one fluff.
There's maternity leaves as a bunch of
other factors. There are less crazy,
less ambitious. They don't have as much
testosterone. Obviously they're not.
It's fucking crazy man. Or be willing
to work themselves into the grave.
And when they're working side
by side doing the same job,
there's almost no disparity at all.
There's a few jobs where men get paid
more than women, but it's not much.
And it's certainly not
70 cents to the dollar.
And this is one thing that gets touted
out over and over again by people.
But it's just not true. I had no idea.
I'll look ahead of friend of mine who,
I've got an argument about it
when he's talking about divorce,
where we were talking
about a buddy of ours,
a that got fucked in a
divorce and he goes, hey,
maybe it's to make up for the fact that
women only make 70 cents an hour. I go,
okay.
The fact that you say that
drives me fucking crazy
because you think it's a good
point, don't yet. And he goes, yeah, I do
you ever research that? And he goes, no,
but it's a fact. I go, it's not
a fact. I go, it's not a fact.
They make 70 cents compared to
[inaudible]. Yes. The Guy said this.
He's the guy who likes to argue. He's
a friend of mine, likes to argue.
He's one of those guys. Use the
words. You just gotta. Yeah,
you gotta walk away from it. No,
he's a good guy. He's a good guy,
but he's got a fucking problem.
He doesn't like when he doesn't know
something and when he doesn't know
something, he would go, he
doesn't go, Holy Shit. Really,
he goes, that's not true.
And I go, what the fuck? It's true.
It's fucking true. Like go Google it.
Like we got an a big
fucking crazy or web series.
I want to watch you guys drive
from here to San Francisco.
Just watching you losing your shit.
It fucking trope.
A couple of times we've
gotten in these arguments,
we've gotten in like three of them.
And it's like, I, when I'm not,
when I don't know something,
I'll say, I don't know.
Or if someone says something and I
didn't know that, I'll go, holy shit.
Is that true? He's the opposite.
He's like, that's not true. So, Oh,
if I don't know something,
I'll do a bit on it twice.
Twice this fucking guy's done this.
Besides it being like,
I know what I'm talking about. I did
a bit on the wage gap on my new, uh,
my new special. Yeah. Well, there
you go. Well, my old thing was like,
how the fuck did they find out what
everybody makes you just call up the IRS.
Can we get 32 is on everybody? They're
going to give you that information.
Well. Uh, I dunno. I Dunno. I have
no idea, but all I know is what,
it's harder for them straight across
the board. That is the, for women,
just everything is harder and
all of our lives are easier.
That's the overall fucking message. You
say you're being sarcastic? I am. Nah.
It's just like I have one of
my favorite jokes of all time.
What about motherhood being the
hardest job in the world? He goes,
how's the hardest job in the world when
you weren't fucking pajamas all day?
Yeah. No job you can do in your pajamas.
I loved that bit. My wife hates it.
No, no, I'm not saying it's not
fucking no, but it's fun. Yeah.
It's obviously difficult, but it's a
funny point still whole thing. Yeah. Yep.
Go work in an oil rig that fucking blows
up and as you jump into the fucking
like on fire water going underneath that
and then he's just sitting there with
second degree burns
and salt fucking water,
hoping that coast guard gets there
before the shark eats you alive.
I talk to me about your,
talk to me about the terrible twos.
I have a friend of mine who works at a
oil rig in Canada in northern Alberta
where it gets 50 below zero and I go,
well,
how do you do it cause they work outside.
I go, how do you do it? He goes, well you,
you keep the truck running and you work
for about seven to 10 minutes at a time
and then you have to go inside the truck
for about a half an hour. I go, really?
He goes, yeah. He goes,
you can't take any more cause you any
exposed skin you have is. He goes,
you try to cover your face up as much
as possible. You put a ski mask on,
but just your eyes just all around your
eyes is all fucked up like everything's
fucked up. It's like it's just too cold.
You just can't do it. 50 below zero.
They just worked for
short stretches of time.
Then they go in the car and then the
other guy will go out while he's in there
and then he'll go out for like 10 minutes
and then they take a break for another
10 15 minutes. Then the other
first guy, we'll go back out again.
All of those shows make me so
thankful that I'm a comedian.
Those fucking crab fishing shows
the fucking worst job you had this as far
as physically like I will kill myself.
Perform 30 if I fucking do this. Out of
high school, I've worked on a, uh, uh,
there was a knights of Columbus Hall that
was having a wheelchair ramp built and
I had a carry cement bags and pressure
treated lumber every day and I only
lasted a little over two weeks.
I think I lasted eight days.
I was a gopher on a construction site.
We will,
we will roofing in June or July. And I
just remember having to bring up those,
first of I brought the Ra, I bought
the wrong color, fucking shingles.
They wanted the fucking ebony one and this
was off at Bama. What the fuck it was.
So I had to go all the way back,
unload the fucking things.
I loaded on load some more back, brought
the fucking things back. I just remember,
dude, it was just like, I
never ate so much in my life.
Like I'd eat like three sandwiches
and like a half hour later I'd be like
starving and just wait was just falling
off of me. I was just like, dude,
what the fuck? This is insane. And,
but the thing was if I hung
in there for like a month,
I would've got my sea legs. But
I, I just was like, no. But I,
I didn't have it. I
knew it. I always knew.
I always knew like when I play drums
and everything like that as much,
every time I thought I was getting good,
I go into guitar center and some eight
year old kid would get on a kit and I'd
be like, holy fuck. I was like, dude,
I would pay you to give me lessons.
And it's just like that when you switch,
whatever you're trying to do,
when you see like a kid come in and he
fucking blow, I mean, blows your way.
It's just like, it's just like, all right,
I, I, this is, this is a hobby bill.
This is a hobby. Well, he's
not doing construction.
It's definitely not a fucking hobby.
It's just brutal. Backbreaking Labor.
There's inc this is a gift as far as like
seeing how things go to get, Oh yeah,
dude. There's an art to
everything. [inaudible] Louis
Ck is a fucking contractors.
Oh God, no. I mean as
far as building houses,
but I mean laboring like
carrying bags of cement.
There's no fucking art carrying
bags of cement. But no,
but they would give me
shit to do, like, you know,
make this fucking miter cut 45 and I fuck
the same, cut up three times in a row.
It was so to frame a door jam and I kept
measuring to the inside of the corner,
rather the outside of
the corner of members.
The third time I did it that my boss
just looked at me, grabbed the wood,
and he looked at me the whole time,
walked up to the frame and never,
never took his eyes off me and the frame
was behind him and he just stuck it to
the fucking wall and just stared at me.
I was so embarrassed. It was just like,
Oh God, dude. He's like, dude,
you're, you're going through,
you went through like fucking $20 worth
of stock to make one fucking cut. Like,
what are you doing? And I was
just like, ugh. And I was just,
I didn't even pick up my show.
I didn't even pick up my check.
I drove up to the site,
I work Monday through Friday,
and then Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
I drove up to the site and I just looked
at it and my body and everything just
said, dude, fuck this. And I just
kept driving. He never called,
why would he call me? I'm the guy who
wasted lumber. He doesn't give a shit.
He got free labor out of me and
I didn't give a fuck. And, um,
I forget what I did after that,
but that was a rough time for me.
But like, I always knew, like if I,
if I didn't like a job and
stuff like that, so it's
like the Deniro thing and uh,
what was that? The heat you gotta
be willing to walk at any moment.
You gotta be willing to fucking walk.
You got to know what's bad. Yeah.
That was it.
That was the probably the toughest
physical job that I had and it was also a
good, it was a good lesson because it
was a lesson that like if you worked for
somebody else and you're just doing labor,
you just doing just mindless labor.
You don't have any time for anything else.
You think you got eight hours in a day
and there's still another 16 you'll get
shit done. You're exhausted, you fucking
beaten down. I would go to the gym.
I try to work out and I remember trying
to hit the bag and I just had nothing.
There was nothing that I'd never felt so
tired in my life and I was only like 18
I should have been full of
piss and vinegar. I just,
I was just dead and I remember
like all my ambition wheels,
we're just ramp it up. I was like,
okay, this is not my fucking future.
I've got to figure out what
the fuck I'm doing cause I,
I had these delusions that I was going
to become a carpenter. I was like, wow.
Getting the union, I'll start building
houses. That's a good gig. Which it is.
You know, if you're, that's what I thought
I was going to do. Yeah. You know what,
it's a good gig if you're the guy telling
the people to go build a fucking house.
But if you're the guy out the poor
in the forms, you've noticed that,
that's mostly young guys like that as a
fucking young him even like landscaping,
like after a while you got to get a
crew and you've got to be the guy like
sending the crews out. Cause there's
only so long that you can just like,
I feel like like laborers and that they
have like the same career trajectory is
like a professional athlete.
Somewhere around 35 to 38,
your body's going to be
like, dude, I can't, I can't,
I can't fucking do this anymore.
He just break down.
There was a w I had a bulging
disc in my neck and I went to a,
an MRI place and,
uh,
there was a lady who went in before
me waiting and this, uh, lady, uh,
I was looking at different people's
Mris and this lady had the most fucking
ridiculous cartoon bulge of her disc.
Some poor woman who,
uh,
I think she worked in a
laundromat or something like that,
just carrying baskets of clothes.
And her back was just so fucked up and
she was probably like 40 years old or
something like that. Came
over your hair from, you know,
Mexico or Guatemala or something. And I
remember looking at her back like in the,
like, this poor lady has no
choice. She has to go to work.
There's no way around this. And there's
no jobs for her other than this, you know,
like what she's,
she can't speak English.
Like she's got to deal with
the fuck she's got to do.
And she had you went into her chart,
Huh? He started reading right there.
It was just sitting up
there on the screen now.
And I asked the guy who's back his hand,
he goes, it's hers. I go, Holy Shit. I go,
his mind look that bad. He goes, no. He
goes, that's bad. He goes, that's bad.
It's real bad. Like she
could barely walk. Look,
she had sciatica up and down
her leg. Oh, I had that. Yeah.
Well that's what that is.
What cy Attica is a bulging disc to
disc that's pressing against the nerves.
You had it would you do about it? I
went to a misuse that helped. Oh yeah.
And she, she works on a, she's a
magician dude. She started with like,
uh,
I can't remember who she
started with, but how it came through
me was through my drum teacher.
So it was like MMA people.
Ah, okay. And then, uh,
you know, the whole sum drummer, a
guitarist or something was into MMA,
fucked up something and they
say, go to my, my suits.
And then she got all the
musicians with like, uh,
one of the tendinitis and all that
shit in the forearms. And then, uh,
it came around to me through my drum
teacher. And, uh, she, she's like,
I made like my left side was fucked up
like the left leg and she started with my
right shoulder. Cause your rights holders
compensating for your left side. Yeah.
So she was doing the whole either let's
try to get some information, you know,
see what's going on here. And then
she'd do something I just go like,
and she'd be like, she'd just be like, she
be like, okay, there's some information.
All right. And then scale of one
to 10, the pain and dude like, um,
she, what she did for me, like
literally she went so fucking deep.
It was like these memories come out.
I remember my brother used to just
give me charley horses and shit for no
fucking reason. You remembered it?
Yeah. Like, like it was a store in La.
So like the pain of it, like
it just pops up. I just,
I wouldn't be like literally thinking
and you just have the thought like I am,
I probably used to always kick
me in the fucking leg there.
And there was another one.
I remember I was playing pickup
hockey and I had no stuff.
All I had was the fucking, uh, the,
the helmet and the gloves and the skate
had like sweatpants and like a fucking
tee shirt or whatever. And I'm out there
like an asshole and I've, you know,
going down the ice and all of a
sudden the other team gets it.
So I pop over to fucking
start skating backwards.
I caught an edge and just went up in
the air and just landed on my left ass
cheek and fucking that hose. I,
dude, I landed so fucking hard.
Like I couldn't breathe in. My eyes
were, it's like literally been,
when you skate skating, it's like being
thrown out of a moving car, right?
So I got up and everyone was laughing. I
fucked up my elbow, you know, it's hockey,
so just, ah, I'm fine. You know,
I get to the bench and I was fine
it and a couple of shifts later,
it kind of worked itself out
and I had bruised my leg so bad.
It was like three days later I was on the
road and I was showering or something.
I just saw on the side of my leg,
it looked like I'd sat in
Greece or something and I
then I looked all the way to
the back of my leg. It looked like
someone took a pipe and just said,
fucking whacked me. As hard as you
could have crossed the back of my leg.
It looks like this straight fucking line.
And I think my sciatic nerve thing was,
which is a combination
of all of that shit.
And then there was that
last thing that did it.
So she fucking worked
all the way out of that.
She gave me all these stretches and then
I found like a good chiropractor and
all that. And um, I been so good
now. Yeah, I'll do it. I couldn't,
I couldn't even sit down
because of, uh, my, my,
my feet were starting would
start to tingle and stuff
with numbness is way worse
than p.
That's beyond pain is what I heard.
It's still the numbness thing is
worse. So she goes, all right,
we're going to work you from
numbness down to pain and then pain,
hopefully down to that. And not just, I
just started going every fucking week,
but uh,
I've got a machine I have to show you.
It's called a reverse hyper answer
machine that decompresses your back while
strengthening it. It's your,
your lift weights with it.
You lift your legs up and
then it strengthens your back.
And then as you lift the
legs, all this shit. Well,
I work for the ultimate
fighting championship. I mean,
I've been an athlete my whole life. Every
time I get this fucking chamber right?
Pay attention to stuff. I
mean, that's what I do. I mean,
I've been intention to the wrong shit.
I've been doing martial arts
and tells a little kid, I mean,
maintaining your body's
a big part of that.
It's one of the most difficult parts of
martial arts is not getting injured all
the time. Your con, because martial arts
are all about hurting people, right?
So it's practicing,
hurting each other.
So like you have to find good
partners and then you'll, oh,
he's that guy in class then goes to
fucking heart. There's always that.
That's Charlie made chrom about that guy.
Yeah, that's a big problem. Sent me an,
I only lasted a couple of weeks
of the Dojo. My fucking Aidy deal.
Maybe I'll learn how to cook now.
You know, I've left so I never,
but I was just like, all right, here's
the deal. You're going to go down there.
When was this? Oh Beck, we do in
the rich bitch tour. Really? Yeah.
You were doing what kind of martial
arts? Reading, whatever style he has.
His fucking black dude. I only, I
only lasted like two weeks. I fucking,
I actually took Jujitsu with dom fig.
Did you really?
In the late nineties I lasted like five
weeks of doing that actually did our
right. I did all right.
But then the guy teaching,
he couldn't speak English and this lady
like dislocated like her fucking rib
cage can, something fucked up happened
and he didn't know what to do.
And I just remembered like, you know, I
was coming home with bruises and shit.
It was like, that was like
when pilot season you could
actually get on something.
And I was just like,
the fuck am I doing?
Why don't I make enough money where
I have security that when you get to
actually get on something funny, you
remember development deals. Yeah.
And Shit could actually happen.
You go to Montreal and get
a deal and then to be set.
I just remember the guy who wrote skip
the heap. It's like this. Oh no good.
It's like this Ah, is good. That was the
whole fucking class Portuguese. Yeah.
Like these, no, like this escape,
escape shrimp, skip the heat.
Whatever the fuck he was saying. And
um, you know, I, I learned some shit.
I still know if I'm on my back,
how to get somebody into an arm bar part.
It's probably, well it was probably, I
look at martial arts, it's like comedy,
so like I think that that worked in the
late nineties but now that would be,
it'd be like a Corny joke now and I
just think like that movie like, Dude,
you're going to fucking try that.
Like an eight year old knows
how to get out of that.
Like you're funny at the office.
You think you're going to go kill it.
The Ryman auditorium. Yeah,
right. That's the difference.
It's more like a time thing where like
that was probably state of the art shit,
whatever. We stayed in the yard then.
I mean you're talking to it. Oh my God.
I was like 18 years ago.
There's no fucking way that move.
Everybody knows that moves.
It's like playing drums.
Well actually all the standard old school
moves in Brazilian Jujitsu are still
good. They're all still good.
If you're good. I'm like,
there's some guys that are really good at
what you would call basic is a classic.
Yeah, basics. A weird word.
And people get upset when you
say they're Jujitsu's very basic,
but some of the best guys ever
have what you call basic Jujitsu.
It's not that it's basic,
it's just they have only a
amount of moves that they use,
but they have them sharpened to a
razor's edge and it's not that they not,
they're not capable of
doing everything else.
Just some guys like there's guys that
are known for just having a guillotine
choke.
That's all they do and you just got to
avoid that fucking guillotine choke and
they might still get you with it.
There's some guys that just
wind by triangle all the time,
only by triangle and there's
guys who only win by, he'll hook.
There's like a bunch of different guys.
Who's is the California kid? Uriah Faber.
Oh Dude,
that guy's hilarious.
Did you see him when he was on
the ultimate fighter? Sure. Okay.
That thing that he,
when he gave that kid shit early on
when he was trying to make this show
[inaudible] and whatever he got
caught and pick a move, whatever,
the fucking rear naked choke or something
like that. And then when the kid,
when the kid goes in and he loses rear
naked choke and daisy went out like a
Uriah just goes like, yeah, he goes,
that's what he's known for. Look them up.
And what I loved about that,
he was like old school parenting,
like no fucking sympathy.
It's just like it.
And I thought it was a very empowering
thing to do to that person. Like if he,
once he got past the defeat, like you'd
be sitting there going like, yeah,
what the fuck? You know, that
this is what the guy did.
Let him beat you with anything else. But
that, that's so easy and this is on me.
It's so much easier said
than done. It's, it's a,
it's incredibly difficult to stop
someone who's really good at something.
If they're really good at all. I
don't think I'd have a problem. Joe.
I rented the last 20 years.
What's the, uh, what was we got to wrap
up. I do by like an hour here, so like,
uh, gimme all, all things, Joe Rogan,
uh, where we can see you in a UFC.
Things coming up.
We talked earlier,
there's this giant one giant one in
Madison Square Garden because the UFC was
illegal in New York for 19 years and
it was all because of corruption.
This is a funny story. The Culinary
Union, the guys who used to own the UFC,
they sold to UFC. But the guys who used
to own the UFC also own station casinos,
they own red rocks and they owned
a bunch of different uh, casinos,
like I think 22 separate casinos,
maybe even more.
And all their casinos were nonunion.
And this is a vote by the,
the casino themselves. Like they got
paid well and I guess they just decided,
look, we don't, we don't need to be union.
So the culinary union was trying to
muscle the owners of the UFC into going
union. And so the way they
would do it is, I mean,
they have a bunch of
different things they do.
They'll stand out and to culinary union
strong. They're huge. They're huge.
And they met those knives that they
managed to keep the UFC out of New York.
And then one of the guys that was in
their pocket got arrested for corruption.
He was the main guy that was
keeping the UFC out in New York.
He went down last year at a corruption
and right after he went down,
they passed it in New York state because
it was passed in every single day.
And they told the public that it was
all that human cockfighting. Exactly.
But meanwhile they had kickboxing,
boxing, everything else was legal,
but they wouldn't let the UFC in.
And so finally,
it's legal now and now that it's
legal and also there's new owners.
So the Culinary Union doesn't have a
beef with these new owners because they
don't even have any casinos.
And the,
the new event that they're going to put
in Madison Square Garden has three world
title fights, uh, for
former world champions.
Three different fighters or fought
for the title before. I mean,
it's a fucking unbelievably stacked card.
The greatest card in the
history of Mcgregor's fight,
Conor Mcgregor's fighting Eddie
Alvarez is, it's a two, two, um,
there's three title fights,
but there's two champions in the,
in the final Conners.
The featherweight champion.
Eddie Alvarez is the lightweight champion,
and if Connor wins,
it'd be the first guy to hold two
titles simultaneously in the UFC.
How do you get in that Conor McGregor
shape? Is it too late for me at 48 no, no.
You can do it tomorrow and he's just
drill on. I'm going to give you a pill.
I'm going to give you an that.
I'm going to give you a mindset.
I'm going to teach you the mindset.
You can't tell you're just fucking
with you though. Oh you think? No.
I thought I had hope.
I had fucking Ho.
He's getting great shape.
He's like,
you're fucking remember Tommy Hearns like
that level shredded or Tommy was like
a six foot tall fucking middleweight
like somehow we could make like what?
What does middleweight one 40 well he
was one 47 when he fought sugar ray.
Leonard was welterweight and money.
Yeah. Unbelievable. He was just like,
just like, it was like you drew them.
Like how do you get that fucking shredded,
that tiny waist and big broad
shoulders and they're ridiculous.
Right hand at reach. Yeah. Well when
he knocked out, uh, Roberto Duran,
that's one of the sick, it was a hook,
right? Uh, I think it was a right hand.
He face planted them. I think you
hit him with a bunch of things,
but I think he hit him when he do.
You dropped him twice but then he face
planted on with her right hand were Duran
just felt like a tree. I don't
want that. Yeah, like out.
Yes, exactly. Like Marquez.
So I'm Conor McGregor is not in the
best shape. This is what's interesting.
I mean he's obviously in great shape,
but he's got a problem with his endurance
and it's one of the things that makes
this fight interesting.
Like he got tired,
he has explosive movements,
he uses up a lot of energy.
He's so fucking fast.
He's so fast and so explosive that
when you have that style of fighting,
it's like sprinting. Whereas
Nate Diaz, the guy fought,
was more of like a marathon
runner. Like Nate. I love Nate.
Nate's awesome and so is his brother Nick.
But their style is more like they don't
go 100% they don't use 100% of their
energy with every punch. They're more
like sixties maybe 70% and they're always,
they're always fresh and they
do a lot of marathon running.
They do a lot of triathlons and
they're always doing endurance work.
So the their endurance is a big part of
their ability to recover and push a pace
that most people can't survive from.
So Connor's not that guy.
Condoms as against people like Nate d,
it's like towards the end he did
a lot of looking at the clock,
did a lot of running away
to kind of reset you ran.
Literally ran away from him and reset
and you know, smart for reminding me.
Went to,
when I first did stand up and Steve Sweet,
he was late and I was on a material and
I just kept looking at the back door.
Like the comment is he can come in.
I got nothing left.
I remember those days, the
Hell Brockton, Brockton,
Nick's comedy stop number.
Then you stood up on that.
Like it was like your mother's office
stages where it was a really small stage,
like a giant Unisex.
You standing on top of her fucking
refrigerator for whatever reason,
and you're like looking down
on the people. It was almost
like this Andy Kaufman,
like talk show desk. But it was the
stage. I don't know if I did Brockton.
I don't know if I did the cow loon, I'm to
it. By then I might've been gone. I did.
Uh, I did the, the Randolph,
I did Brockton Framingham and then,
uh,
I think that was it for the Nixon.
Then there was of course the one downtown.
I never just framing him either,
I don't think,
I think that was gone to cal Lutheran.
Of course the loans do the column.
I didn't giggles Mike Clarke's room.
Did you ever do that giggles on route
one the street. And uh, so anyway,
the Conor McGregor
thing, like he's not, he,
I would say he's doesn't have
the best cardio in the world.
You can't say he's not in great shape
because he did go five rounds with Nate
DHEAS. But it's just, it's not, he's not
the same kind of shape. They're like,
like Nick Diaz has swam
from Alcatraz five times,
gets in the fucking ocean,
which shark infested northern California.
Water's sweating.
And then you have to be in incredible
shape to divvy out of your fucking mind to
that too.
But you've got to be an incredible shape.
I've got a buddy of mine who just
got done running the big foot 200.
He ran 204 fucking miles.
205 205 miles in 78 hours.
Three days are running three and a half,
three days a second way.
Woken word. Yep. It's called
the big foot 200 all document.
It's like running 60 to 70 miles a day.
Oh yeah, yeah. Maybe be less than that.
Fifth. Yeah. Something like
that. Yeah. Something like
that. I remember the numbers.
Yeah. Seventies 21 six 63. I'm going
63 miles. I like what you're saying.
Three three is nine 18. Yeah. He, um,
he's run hundreds a couple of times.
He actually ran a hundred in June to
prepare for the 200 in, uh, August crate.
So his half marathon is a hunt,
is four marathons basically.
Essentially he's a fucking animal.
I mean, he runs a, does he,
does he run with those feet sneakers
and know we can see the toes now he's
sponsored by under Armour. So who wears
the under armor? A fat tire shoes.
It's Nice cushiony shoe.
But he's um, he's, he,
he'll run 1450 miles a day every day.
Who came up with that big foot?
200 savages. Fucking barbarians.
His name's Cameron Hanes.
He's a professional bowhunter.
And uh,
to get in shape for bowhunting is bow
hunting is all about like climbing up
mountains and shit.
Especially when you're hunting elk.
I hunt with that guy and it's fucking
exhausting and I'm in pretty good shape.
I'm not in great shape,
but I'm pretty good shape.
I could barely keep up with them.
I mean barely.
He's barely out of breath
and I'm fucking dying.
I'm just drenched in sweat heaving
and trying to follow cause like,
well you don't want to bring me along
for that one. That or anybody else.
I mean the way he does it is a very
unique where he's like one of the most
successful elk hunters in the world and
one of the reasons is shape cause he can
get to places like you see an elk
and the elk goes over the ridge.
The key is you got to get to that fucking
else quickly because it's moving over
that ridge. Right? So if
you, if you look at an elk
and it goes over the top of the
hill and goes to the other side,
the quicker you can get to that,
the closer it's going to be that hill.
You've got to get within 60
yards and you don't know how,
how far it's going to move in the
time it takes you to get up there.
Well it takes me maybe 10 minutes to get
up there. It'll take him two minutes.
So about those extra eight minutes,
that fucking Alex, way out of range.
You'd go down the hill after it.
It's going to see you.
You're never going to get a shot at
it. So he has, we shot opportunities.
You have any like uh,
like uh,
the one that got away sort of shot like
you had it, you lined it up and whatever.
Get exhaled at the wrong time and
you missed it and then it took off.
That's an elk hunting.
You'd I had five of those two weeks ago.
There's five of those at least.
Maybe six. Yeah, we hunted for,
I shot that one with a rifle because we
just couldn't get close enough with a
bow. It was just five. Do you
feel your guide going like, dude,
are you gonna fucking kill one here?
Is there more pressure?
That's just how it is. Elk
Hunting is hard. [inaudible]
you go, when are you going?
When are you going to go a wild boar
hunting again? I'm going with you.
You and I are going to go,
we're going to schedule something soon.
We'll schedule something.
I'm what's schedule something
like maybe after Christmas. Yeah.
Get me an Uzi and then I'll go,
I'm going to get you a yes. Ah,
as it comes running.
Cause those things I saw when
I was standing watching the uh,
the chef there from hell's kitchen. Um,
ah, God damn. And I said his name earlier.
I'm the worst. Yeah. Ramsey. He made
his scrambled eggs again this morning.
My wife fucking loves it.
What kind of scrambled eggs?
Oh Dude. He fucking, he puts,
this is what he does. He, first of
all, he gets, he gets the pepper pot,
a little pan going, a little
olive oil, put some, uh,
tomato is still on the
vironment with some mushrooms.
He just lets that fucking sizzle.
And then he takes three eggs and like
a dollop of fucking butter puts it in
there. It doesn't mix. It
already puts it on the flame.
And then he starts mixing this thing
around. He talks about all the chemistry.
You don't want to mix it
before you put it in there.
It doesn't put any salt in
there cause some reason that
does it. He's like, oh no,
he's now off to hate CDA and yet do
it cause they hate, it's in here.
I've watched it a Zillion fucking
times when I'm watching this thing.
Heats in the pan hates into pants. So
that's the one thing that I learned. Um,
I learned from this guy, uh,
uh, Sheff, uh, Roy who will, uh,
Roy Choi who started the whole
gourmet food truck thing.
I did like fab roads doing the shooting
this thing and I went over there and I
got to, Sidney taught me this shit
about the grilled cheese sandwich.
And what I learned about these guys is,
dude, it's all controlling the heat.
Like my whole shit is
just like medium high.
I'm like medium high for 10 minutes
and it's like you're not cooking,
you're just standing there like a
fucking bouncer or shit. It's like,
so he got manipulated it.
So he does all of that and when it gets
to a certain level of a coming together,
then he takes this creme fresh and
puts it in there. What is creme fresh?
I don't know what the fuck it is, but it's
delicious. Right? And then you get it,
you bring it back back on the heat and
in salt in, right. He puts that shit in.
You go and you just keep stirring this
fucking thing and it almost looks like
it's water. You don't think it's done.
You taste it. You're like, oh my God,
this is great. Then you
take it off, right? No wait.
You chop up a little bit of dill.
You sprinkle it up,
you mix it in there and then the
by then the sourdough toast pops
up a little olive oil on that.
He put the fucking scrambled eggs on now
with the fucking tomatoes and mushroom,
give it to your wife over,
Woo over.
But then they love it and then they keep
telling you to make it and you decide,
uh, let's just do the old scrambled
egg with the cheese in it.
I got to get you some eggs. We have
our own chickens. I have 23 chickens.
How long can they lay eggs before you
have to fucking retire them? Well,
they just stop laying eggs after awhile.
But then you still on right now
I just let them live. They just,
they just live and then they die though.
I've had a bunch of just die. How long,
how long die.
I've had chickens for now,
I want to say five years, somewhere
around there. Four or five years,
maybe five years. And um, they
just fucking die sometimes.
I've had like a,
but I have some of them that are like
five years old said it's still five years
old. Just picture this chicken
at his desk, you know, this,
those classic 1950 [inaudible] attack.
You know,
back then when nobody knew shit about
fucking heart attacks, it was terrifying.
What does everybody's
hearts just fucking stop?
And they were all eating bacon in fucking
Martinis and all this shit that had no
idea. And that was back when
they, you know, they had no
respect for martial arts.
It was all like,
I'll tell you another,
it's stronger than a
good old Sunday punch.
And they'd be sitting there eating fucking
stakes and people would just dropping
right left, like dropping dead. I
know you like conspiracy theories,
you look a good conspiracy theory.
It's been a good one. The good,
I don't like the Rogan.
Here's a really,
once he get one lumped in with people
who have silly, I understand that.
Here's a real, why don't we move
and it was in the New York Times,
they prove that scientists were paid off
by the sugar industry in the 1960s Oh
yeah, I have. Absolutely. They were
paid off to make saturated fat.
The culprit for all
these diseases and fat,
fat people and heart attacks
when it was actually sugar.
I'm 11 tries to tell him the blame away
from sugar and pin it on saturated fat.
So basically scientists,
bacon is actually not bad for you.
Saturated fat is actually not bad for you.
There's a giant illusion that cholesterol,
everybody thinks to collect.
All your cholesterol is high.
Dietary cholesterol barely moves
the needle on blood lipids,
blood lip. It's like when they
measure your diet, when you're bent,
measure cholesterol in your
blood has to do with the last.
Sounds great to me that you're
also a standup comedian. You don't,
you don't have a white lab coat on. I'm
sitting here like, okay, Doctor Rogan,
you read,
read these things.
But what gives people high cholesterol
was first of all the LDL cholesterol, HDL,
cholesterol,
the good cholesterol and bad cholesterol,
and you can have high of warm as
if you have higher. The other one,
it balances each other out.
I'll send you a podcast if you have
the fucking the time to listen to it.
It's 81 words. Sit there long enough.
You, Farron. It's hard. It's hard.
It's hard to sit down and listen
to this stuff. But this guy,
Chris crusher was on my
podcast who explained it all
and scientific great names
of all the time. Chris Kresser,
Chris [inaudible], Chris Kresser.
Oh. Um, but anyway, it's
not cholesterol. The, it's,
it's a lot of it is hereditary.
Like if you have high blood pressure or
dietary cholesterol or high cholesterol,
let him and David Lamb and look,
he didn't have an ounce of fat on him and
he needed open heart surgery. Yes. Yeah,
yeah. A lot of that is hereditary. Some
people just get a shit roll the dice.
Just like some kids are born with
leukemia. I mean, it's just a sound.
Something you did. It's not like they've
been smoking since they were a fetus.
You know, my big fitness thing is I'm
big, big time into body weight exercises.
So I'm trying to get myself strong
enough to do a front lever it fucking 48
years away from front lever is
basically you hang from the chin up bar,
you bring your legs straight up and you
hang in there like a fucking table and
you've got to put party
wait behind the bar.
So there's all of these exercises to
explain that. Okay. Sorry. So you,
you just chat them. Do you
remember planking? Yes.
Just imagine if he did it on your back.
You're laying on your back in the air,
but you're hanging from the chin up on
your legs as straight out like that. Okay.
Yeah. So I've been fucking
with that for like months,
trying to build up the strength and I
got myself to the point because the whole
thing is you've gotta be behind the bar.
And what's great is I got this big
head so it kind of fucking, you know,
there's a lot of weight
already behind the bar but,
so I've gotten to a point
now where I can actually,
like I used to be almost hanging upside
down and then gradually you can kind of
bring,
you have your legs in a ball.
So like the way it is
basically underneath it.
And I've gotten to the point now where
I can just start to extend one leg and
then I fall to the ground. They ain't
bad. I'm going to get there though.
You'll get there.
I just want to bust that out one
time cause I got a buddy of mine,
he has a bet with me that when
I'm 70 I can't do 10 pull ups.
So just to fucking Sunday no,
when I turned 70 70 to them
to catch the veteran. Yeah.
As long as you just keep
going, you'll, you'll get,
that's the thing
Stallone's in the 70s yeah.
But if I don't say he could do 10 pushups,
right.
[inaudible] if I don't have that
bet. I understand how that, fuck you.
So it's a great carrot that I'm
chasing them. I understand. Yeah,
you could do that though. It has nothing
to do with age. You can do that move.
She's going to do, it doesn't have to do
with butter. Do Bacon and shit like that.
Lifting,
just going to,
you know the best way to do it honestly
start doing body weight exercises,
do a lot of chin ups and stuff like that,
but do them really slowly.
That's one of the best ways to
really develop like serious strength.
Like a lot of people like to do chin ups.
They like to do those like kipping
Chin ups you see in crossfit.
What I like to do is what's kipping like
ego like you kind of like kick up and
you kick up.
You're saying that's like cheating.
It is like cheating but it's people who
aren't their back on the bench press but
it's a hard workout if you do
a bunch of them, but it's just,
there's a lot of criticisms.
Why does crossfit have to be
done in front of everybody?
Why can't they just stay in there?
Jim,
why are they was running up and
down the street like look at us,
we're working out. Cause it's like,
look at us, we're working out.
Should I be more mature about that? Nope.
Nope. You should rub it in their face.
They're like vegans and a lot of ways
they want you to know what they're doing.
You know, it's like [inaudible]
like that's the, that's
part of the whole thing.
It's like you become,
there's a whole article about that,
about it's replacing
religion for a lot of people.
They become tribal and you get involved
in these group a like group activities
and you,
you identify with that group.
Like you become a crossfitter or you
become a Vegan or you become a lot.
I mean not there's anything wrong
with either one of those. One,
it was like the gym is a good garage.
Jordan is wide open and they're making
all this fucking noise and it's like,
yeah, I work out too. You know,
I, I have the door closed. Ah,
listen to a little iron maiden lately.
But that's part of the fun of it.
They want everybody to know they're
doing it. So you walk by and go, wow,
Billy's in shape. You know, looking at
that, looking at him, he's fucking lifted.
He's doing,
I've been lying.
I've been on says having breakfast and
like outside cafe and all of a sudden 20
these maniacs just run by.
You get to the corner and then
they run back the other way.
You just want to fucking throw
your pancakes out of. Well,
it's worse if you're walking and they,
they fucking almost run you over like,
Hey asshole, this is not a gym. Okay, this
is the sidewalk. Like don't, this is not,
there's not a place for you to conduct
your class. Maybe it's like a dream thing.
Like they think the treadmill
is take up too much energy. No,
I think you are right.
They want people to know what they're
doing and you don't have the space to,
you know, they have a track so they
just had to use a sidewalk. You know,
I've seen that. I've seen like groups
of people run up and down streets.
It's fucking stupid nose in Santa Monica.
It was fucking laughing my ass
stupid sitting there running it.
Fucking accountants,
but crossfit itself.
What it does is it gets people to get
competitive and when they get competitive,
the good thing about it is like
there's a bunch of people around you.
You're all pushing each other. The bad
thing about it is a lot of people, they,
they,
their form falls apart when they start
doing higher repetitions and they get
competitive with it and then
they start getting injured.
I know a lot of fucking people that
have hurt themselves doing crossfit,
a lot of bells. People always
fucked themselves up right
behind every baby. Yeah.
I don't fuck with crap on those.
These are going to do them slowly
and doing with correct form.
The beautiful thing about kettlebells
is you can get a great workout with a
light Kettlebell.
I could get a great workout with a 35
pound Kettle Bell Light Kettlebell,
moving it slowly and controlling in
every step of the way and you can do all
sorts of exercises. Go from one to the
other, one to the other and he'd give a,
you get a full body workout that works.
It's actual functional strength.
Like it'll apply the affluent.
Even the reservation with the,
I'm going all old school,
I got those atomic holds,
you know like did American Ninja Shit,
those little fucking look like
little cannon balls. It was a great,
I got those hanging
from my ceiling and uh,
I'm trying to get the ones that looked
like the num chuck handles and I fucking
went to order the thing and it never came.
And then they sent me an email going like,
did you, you still want them? It's like,
yeah, I order to go to rogue
fitness, rogue fitness.com
they have all that crazy,
well that's what I bought my rack through
those guys and I've got a speed bag
and then I'm going to get those Swedish
buzz and see if I can get myself up to
be able to do a fucking Cuban flag.
Oh Shit. Well, I like to, Shit Lori,
I'm working towards something. I can't
just get on an elliptical everyday,
like I'm doing a half hour and the big
thing is what's my new playlist because I
will get bored shitless with that. But I
feel like with the speed bag, you know,
I suck at that,
but I'm getting a little bit better at it.
I'm like learning something like, you
know, it's funny, my wife wanted it. Um,
it wasn't man enough. I didn't
want to have a thing. But yeah,
it's something cool about doing
it. But do you know, like Julio,
Cesar Chavez didn't even know how to do
that. It's kind of useless for boxing
and it gives you a little bit
of endurance for your shoulders.
But when the fuck is going, last question,
my dream punch. Somebody like this,
imagine someone stood in front of
you and you punched him like this.
I think it was to build up your timing.
Then also build up your arms that you
can keep your arms up shoulder and
Terrence head. Yeah, right. But
Julio, Cesar Chavez, it's hilarious.
He's one of the greatest
boxer of all time.
He always used to laugh because he would
like try to do it and he couldn't do it
like you then you get knock everybody
out in the fucking kill everybody.
I mean he was a fucking monsters and dude,
I'm, I'm, I'm just trying to get into,
in the, uh, I, I, we used to go
to Gleason's gym and, and they,
and they knew why I was there and they
used to call me billary swank, you know,
cause cause a million, million, million,
million dollar baby had just come out.
Oh No. We had a great time. Charlie
Murphy once again gave me the lady there.
He gave me, no, it gave me the
lay of the land. Charlie goes,
you go down there cause
they, okay. He goes,
you're going to be down there about
three weeks. I get a bad Charlie Murphy.
He goes, someone's going to
come up to you and be like, Yo,
how long have you been boxing?
Yo Yo, nice blah blah blah.
Why don't you get in the ring goes do not
get in the ring because he wants to go
in there and try out all the shit that
he doesn't have the nerve to try and get
some professional fighter and you're
going to get fucked up. Right. Exactly.
Three weeks. Whatever the fuck he
said on the nose, this fucking,
this guy comes up, black dude from
Brooklyn starts coming into a white guy,
stand up comedian from the suburbs.
Go, Yo Yo, nice man, you can box.
I just started laughing. I got
to get the fuck Outta here. I go,
I'm not getting the room with you.
When he fucking laughed and walked away
and I told Charlie thinking he would
laugh. You know, Charlie's just
so fucking real deal. He just go,
I fucking told you.
It's like I told you,
Charlie Murphy is one of
the best guys of all time.
I did that Maxim tour with him. I got to
know him. We did 22 dates together. Yeah,
he's a fucking great guy. I
really that dude. I really do.
He's not one of those guys.
My fucking phone went in the toilet.
I lost his fucking number,
so I'm going gonna be able to call him.
I think I got it. I'll give it to
you. Oh, okay. Yeah. I love that.
We've got to wrap this up,
dude. I'm sitting like 9
million hours of traffic. Joe,
you're the fucking best. You've
been one of the top comics for what?
2025 I don't know how many fucking years
since I was in Boston when I saw you at
the cow lune and you did you tigers
fucking bit, which sounds like, oh,
it's just targets. Fucking dude. The
ditch, the noise you made of the,
the tiger was fucking unbelievable.
I still remember your bit making fun of
the chicks out there with the hair like
a giant room. Oh my God,
you're a fucking monster.
So I'm so happy for you that you're a,
you've got another spa special that's
out on Netflix. It's called trigger.
Please watch it. If you love
it, please rate it. So, uh,
you know, stay on the front.
Whatever that fucking scrolly thing
is. And uh, and that's it, man.
You Ain't gonna Hook me up with some
elk meat. Fuck you. Right. Thanks bill.
I really appreciate you don't
feel the same way about you, man.
You're one of my all time favorites.
We're going to have a big hug f. Dot.
All right guys. Thanks for listening. All
right. What's up Bill Burger here, right?
How great was that?
Ah,
the Great Joe Rogan finally got him on
after nine years of doing my fucking
podcast. Finally got him on. Um,
and I didn't do any of the advertising
because I knew that it was going to be
too interesting to sit
there and talk to that guy.
So here's a little bit of advertising.
I what you're thinking. Oh
Shit. Bill, the fucking advertising.
That's boring. Well, not the way I do it.
All right, here we go. We
got a new one here. CSOS see,
so s e so see,
so there you go.
Fuck you man. All right. See,
so was the place for comedy.
They won't tell you how amazing they are,
but I will evidently see.
So is amazing. It's comedy for
comedy nerds by comedy nerds, CSO,
spelled c.
So s e s o is the new ad free streaming
service bringing you hilarious original
specials, handpicked classics,
weeks of standards. The,
and I fucking have mine on there and
not pay me. Yukon's hand up pits,
handpicked classics, weeks of
Standup specials and more, uh,
bingeable economy, comedy
anytime, any way. CSO,
uh, every episode of SNL ever. Really.
Jesus, this is a big fucking thing.
Cause those guys, those guys
hoard those specials. Um,
those episodes including new episodes the
day after the air at the tonight show,
sour and Jimmy Fallon,
Jimmy Fallon from New England
or you did so great. Um,
and late night with Seth Meyers,
the day after they air and they even
have classics like 30 rock parks and
recreation and saved by the bell.
Um,
are those already classics?
See saved by the bell.
Even British comedies like the original
office with that dangerous guy,
Ricky Gervais. Saul, what's he going
to do with the MEC is breaking up
a smoke a cigarette,
the entire money python catalog,
the it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan
Partridge discover the next big names in
comedy and watched the icons before they
made it before they made it big like
Louis Ck, Chelsea Peretti, Amy Schumer,
Paul Burnham and so much more critically
acclaimed originals and exclusive
content like harmonquest created by
comedian Dan Harmon and funny as hell a
variety show featuring such comedians
as Jim Jefferies are Jim Jefferies and
Hannibal Burress. Um, if
you're serious about comedy,
you got to go to seeso streaming.
Anytime Jesus fucking Christ, we get it.
CSO is ad free and it's
just three 99 a month.
That's less than you paid for the Latte
or artists and cold brewed coffee you're
holding right now.
And right now my listeners can
try CSO a free for two months.
When you use Promo code bird
at the checkout, they pointed,
they going to say what CSO stands for.
CSO.
I'm seriously igneous,
hammered egos, sucking Oscars.
I don't fucking know.
Shows what you can get any shows
you can't get anywhere else.
From critically acclaimed original
series to all 40 plus years of SNL CSOS.
The only place that offers every episode
ever made and the new episodes the day
after they air.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com right
now to sign up for too much for free for
promo with the Promo Code Burra checkout.
That's seeso.com Promo Code Burr to just
for the fucking SNL alone. That's great.
Um, all right. Hey, speaking of
Joe Rogan, his, his company on it,
on it has a new product.
It's called emulsified MCT oil.
What the fuck is that?
Well,
we're going to tell you MCT oil is one
of the fastest sources of clean fuel for
the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up
your performance and kickstart a weight
management program. And I should do
that. Rub it right on my stomach. Uh,
there are a lot of MCT oil brands
out there, but none there is none.
Unlike the emulsified MCT oil from Onnit,
what's emulsification?
That's like when you got Balsamic
vinegarette just sitting there, okay.
In the fucking vinegarette goes away from
the Balsamic or vice versa, whatever,
and fucking shit up in.
All of a sudden it's been combined.
It's been emulsified.
You get it.
It's like a carburetor when you got the
air in the fuel mixture and it creates
that foam that you can't drink,
but it looks like a latte.
That's some office suffocation.
Emulsification available.
Three delicious flavors,
coconut, Vanilla and strawberry.
Jesus Christ, that's me right there.
Coconut head, vanilla
skin, strawberry, pubes,
emulsified MCT oil mixes like
a cream easily in your morning.
Coffee without the need for
a black, no mess, no cleanup.
You can even mix it
into your favorite food.
Liquid Billy red face right
here from Onnit right now.
If you go to onnit.com o n n I
t.com/ [inaudible] you can get on,
it's emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
That's on an o and n I
t.com/bird to emulsified MCT oil
for 12% off any and for any reason.
If you don't like it, they'll give
you money back. No questions asked.
You've got nothing to lose.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar
now and get a and get on it. Okay,
what on I got left? Jesus Christ. They
get out of breath from reading out loud.
That's how dumb I am. All
right, seat Geek. Okay.
Buying tickets online for
sports and concerts has been
a confusing process for a
long time. Now. There's nothing confusing
about it. It cost a fucking fortune. Um,
it's always hard to find the best deal
for that game or show you want to go to
and none of those older tickets
sites want to change that.
But seek geek is different.
They've come along and created an amazing
APP and website that makes it easier
for them than ever for fans
to buy and sell tickets, seek.
He does all the price comparisons for
you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get
the best possible deal and
see Keke wants to help you
get the best mu, the best bang for
your buck. That's why even ticket,
that's why every ticket on Siki
is given a grade based on value.
You'll immediately see any underpriced
seats and be able to find the best deals
that fit your budget.
Best of all,
my listeners get $20 $20 rebate off
their first SeatGeek purchase to get your
$20 rebate on tickets.
How do I do that, man?
Download the SeatGeek APP.
Go to the settings tab and
click add and add a promo code.
Enter the Promo Code Berbee you are our
SeatGeek will send you $20 off after
you've made your first ticket purchase.
Download the SEATGEEK APP and enter
the Promo Code bird today. Jesus,
I was doing all right there. Oh, Jay's
is. Here we go. Our old friends here.
Everybody here, they are
returning. Once again, both Zip,
right?
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place ad isn't
enough to find quality candidates. Will.
What do I do? Man? If you
want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all
the top job sites. Is it hard? No.
It's easy with all fucking Zip,
right?
[inaudible] dot com you can post your job
to 100 plus job sites including social
media networks like the Facebook,
like the Twitter,
all with one single click there.
Find candidate in any kind of candidate
in any city or any industry. What?
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in. Like all add hot.
Bordered it down to Florida to
Ziprecruiter's. Easy to use interface.
No juggling emails, no juggling
emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates.
Rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today.
Why Zip?
Okay.
Dot. Cop has been used over one by over
1 million businesses and right now you my
listeners,
my listeners can post jobs on zip,
Rick
[inaudible]
for free by going free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] that's
ziprecruiter.com/bird one more
time to get free. Go to [inaudible]
brick
third.com/bar
all right, next one. Last and final.
Sorry, that's getting nauseous. I know,
but there's only so many with different
ways to read. All right. Oh Jesus.
It's tracker.
We're all loses Newsweek reports.
The average American wastes 55 minutes
a day looking for things they own but
can't find. Share a story when you've
lost something you needed. Yeah,
I lost my soul when I fucking
do something like that.
Just give me the copy and I'll fucking
read it. Oh yeah. I remember the time.
I couldn't find my mittens. Oh boy. You
know we had a snowball fight coming up.
I get it. You put this fucking thing on
shit and you don't lose it anymore. Yeah.
For some reason they're going
to write 10 pages of Shit.
Tracker makes losing
things a thing of the past.
And I'll tell you how to get
one for free in a minute.
Tracker is a coin size device that
locates misplaced keys, wallets, bags,
computers, dildos, anything in seconds.
Just track tracker to your smart phone,
attach it to anything and find his
precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. Lose your
phone, press a button. Ah,
there it is on track or your phone
rings even when it's on silent.
Grapey tracker is finding over
a million. Jesus Christ. Cleo,
could you go take a fucking fleet?
Fleabag
yeah,
you've been shaken story in the whole
fucking time. We're supposed to be a t.
O look at me like that. Come
here buddy. Come here. I'm sorry.
You just look at me like, dude, I will
fucking rip your throat out if I want to.
Now it's up on the couch. That's
all I want. Wanted. Good, good.
All right, tracker is, um, wait,
am I tracker is finding over a
million misplace items each day.
Order yours and never lose
anything. Again, listen to
the show. Get a free tracker.
Bravo with any order,
go to the t h e tracker.com
and enter Promo code burn.
The hardest thing you'll ever
have to find is there a website?
Go to tracker.com right now and enter
the Promo Code Burger for free tracker.
What? Free tracker. Bravo with any
order again, that's tracker.com
Promo Code Bar. Did anybody
see that fucking ad on TV
that was making fun of uh,
Ohio state the way they go.
D Ohio State University.
They were talking about things that
you, that you're sick up. They go,
are you sick of um,
dramatic pauses after football players
say the name of their university and they
had this guy like doing like cross
side and he just went like Thi Brockton
community college. I butchered
it, but you got to see it.
The guy's performance on it is tremendous.
It's as funny as how unfunny
the way I just did it.
Look at you cleo. What are you
doing? You want to go outside?
Cleo? Can I get it at a high level before
we leave? Clear. Go get off the couch.
Get off the couch. All right, here we go.
The key is you just have to
make eye contact. I'm going
to go for this year. Cleo,
do you want to go outside?
Cleo?
Oh, there you go. Good girl. All
right, I'll talk to you later.